Does sex smell?
Science says yes!
But not in the way you're thinking, ya perverts.
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - to talk about
everyone's favorite subject, pheromones.
Now we've been told for years and years that
pheromones influence our behavior - and help
us choose mates - but it's always been kind
of a question mark as to how much of a difference
they really make.
Humans in particular, have more secretion
and sweat glands than any other primate, and
the organ we use to detect pheromones is called
the vomeronasal organ, or VNO.
It's a tiny, crescent-shaped bundle of neurons
at the base of each nostril, and almost all
animals have it - from reptiles, to elephants,
to house cats.
What's surprising, however, is that only 30%
of humans were actually born with this organ.
But we can all smell pheromones, right?
So there's gotta be something else that allows
us to detect them.
Well, there is.
Men secrete something called andro, which
is a metabolite of testosterone, in their
sweat and semen.
And women, secret estra, a derivative of estrogen,
in their urine.
Both chemicals are known to trigger arousal
in the opposite sex - but in order to be considered
true pheromones, they have to shape how people
view different genders.
New research from the Chinese Academy of Sciences
in Beijing - confirms that that's exactly
what happens.
For the study, researchers split men and women
up into groups of 24, and then had them watch
this video.
Notice the figure on the left, has a decidedly
female strut - with a lot more hip movement
- while the figure on the right, has a flatter
gait, typical of most males.
The one in the middle - is considered neutral,
meaning it could go either way.
They then asked subjects to inhale either
andro or estra - and judge whether they thought
the neutral walk was more masculine or more
feminine.
Turns out, their judgments depended entirely
on their own sexual preferences.
After smelling andro, the male hormone, straight
women perceived the walk as being more masculine.
But the pheromone had no effect on straight
men.
In contrast, smelling estra, the female hormone
- made straight men perceive the walk as more
feminine.
While straight women, weren't affected.
Even more interesting, is the fact that gay
men followed the exact same response pattern
as straight women.
Meaning homosexual men are more likely to
respond to male pheromones than they are to
female ones.
Oddly enough, homosexual women - fell somewhere
in between.
So neither pheromone made much of a difference.
This supports the classification of andro
and estra as "sex pheromones," but it also
shows that they can influence our perception
of gender - but only in the genders we're
attracted to.
Like most pheromones, the smell is imperceptible
- so all of these decisions that happen are
subconscious - but they're still an important
part of how we interact and perceive each
other.
More importantly, this study shows that pheromones
aren't gender-specific - but rather, sexuality-specific.
Which gives even less ammo to the argument
that sexuality is a choice.
Personally, I think everyone smells gross.
But, I also live in a city with almost no
air conditioning.
And, I attend a lot of gaming conventions.
So, my experience is probably skewed.
Speaking of smelly things - and terrible segueways
- if you want more facts about smelly stuff
- go check out Animalist's new show, Best
Breed Ever!
It tells you everything you wanna know - and
some things you didn't know - about your favorite
breeds of dogs.
FOR EXAMPLE: Did you know that French bulldogs
are banned from most commercial airplanes?
It's true.
And when you hear the reason, it actually
kinda makes sense.
They've got new episodes every Wednesday and
Friday, so go check those out if you're interested.
And in the meantime - if you have questions
or comments about this episode, leave em down
below - and subscribe here for more videos.